und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
von abends im streit über die
impfpflicht für gesundheits und
pflegeberufe hat bundeskanzler scholz
eine art machtwort gesprochen er erwarte
dass das von bundestag und bundesrat
beschlossene gesetz von den ländern auch
umgesetzt werde zitat seines sprechers
wir gehen davon aus dass gesetze
eingehalten werden das ist eine der
vorzüge des deutschen rechtssystems
die schärfe liegt im unterton und lässt
ahnen wie es auf der nächsten bund
länder runde zu gehen könnte die ist für
kommende woche angesetzt und da wird es
außerdem um die 2g regel im einzelhandel
gehen eine reihe bundesländer haben sich
davon bereits verabschiedet in
niedersachsen hatte das
oberverwaltungsgericht die regel schon
im dezember gekippt welche erfahrungen
man dort mit der öffnung gemacht hat
berichtet elisabeth schmid es war ein
großer hoffnungsschimmer mit der
dezember mitten im schleppenden
weihnachtsgeschäft erzählt michael
henkel meyer leiter eines schuhgeschäfts
in hannover einkaufen im einzelhandel
plötzlich durften das auch wieder
ungeimpfte niedersachsen die bilanz seit
dem durchwachsen es läuft nicht wie
erhofft im schuhgeschäft
es ist schon so dass dadurch ein
bisschen mehr kunden gekommen sind wir
können es auch ganz gut vergleichen weil
wir auch geschäfte haben in anderen
bundesländern wo ihnen diese regelung
noch gilt aber die umsätze sind deswegen
nicht exorbitant gestiegen sind minimal
gestiegen und in zahlen heißt das im
vergleich zu vor corinna zeiten
verbuchen einzelhändler in niedersachsen
immer noch einen umsatzrückgang von bis
zu 20 prozent sagt der handelsverband
und führt diese auch darauf zurück dass
es weiter ruhe shopping auflagen gibt
die 2g regelungen gingen eine ffw zwei
masken pflicht kam auf die
infektionszahlen hatte das diesen effekt
niedersachsen lag lange unter dem
bundesschnitt das blieb auch nach dem 16
dezember so nachdem ein gericht zweig
gekippt hatte trotz omikron welle also
ich glaube dass dieser tausch der im
raum steht dass wir sagen wir verstärken
die masken pflicht im einzelhandel auf
sp2 und nehmen dafür zweig weg dass das
eine gute kombination ist das wird die
übertragung eher reduzieren es ist
einfacher zu handhaben und damit glaube
ich insgesamt
richtung erlauben diese erkenntnisse
weitere lockerungen neue hoffnung kommt
von den kliniken wir gehen nicht davon
aus dass wir in den kommenden wochen
eine überlastung in den kliniken erleben
werden und deswegen ist es auch
verantwortlich jetzt schrittweise und
wirklich planvoll einzelne
beschränkungen aufzuheben und damit auch
der gesellschaft ein stück weit ihre
freiheit zurückzugeben
doch der teufel steckt im detail warnen
epidemiologen bislang habe die omikron
welle ältere menschen weitgehend
verschont wir sehen jetzt dass die welle
auch bei den älteren ankommen
dementsprechend steigen auch die zahlen
auf den intensivstationen gerade bei den
älteren an das heißt dann müssen wir
noch ein bisschen warten wenn wir jetzt
vorzeitig zu schnell lockern dann würde
die omikron welle nicht nur höher
sondern auch noch länger und dann könnte
es durchaus sein dass wir noch mal
probleme im gesundheitssektor bekommen
lockern nicht lockern der stimmen kanon
wird immer dissonante auch die
bundesländer streiten wann wie corona
beschränkungen zurückgenommen werden
sollten mahnende worte heute aus
rheinland pfalz wir streben natürlich
möglichst bundeseinheitliche lösungen an
die bevölkerung trägt auch corinna
maßnahmen immer leichter mit wenn sie
bundeseinheitlich beschlossen und
besprochen sind die marschrichtung
zeichnet sich allerdings ab zweig im
einzelhandel wird wohl bald
deutschlandweit vergangenheit sein
solange man der vfb zwei massen trägt ob
man sich im baumarkt mutmaßlich auch
nicht schneller an stecken als im
supermarkt aber bei den 2g oder 3g
regeln ging es der politik natürlich
auch um anreize für ungeimpfte ob
nächste woche noch weitergehende
öffnungen in aussicht gestellt werden
wird man sehen einige andere länder
haben da ja bereits ziemlich radikale
entscheidungen getroffen schweden
dänemark israel
das zu beobachten wird epidemiologen
interessante feldstudien bieten michael
bewerunge berichtet aus tel aviv
der türsteher vom sputnik hat nicht mehr
viel zu tun die kontrollen am eingang
des clubs in tel aviv halten sich in
grenzen seit dieser woche muss niemand
mehr den grünen passt der geimpften und
genießen oder eine negativ test am
eingang zeigen höchstens mal den ausweis
zur alterskontrolle
obwohl die omikron werde noch nicht
vorbei ist beendet israel die meisten
zugangskontrollen das junge publikum
hier findet das richtig
ich mache mir nicht wirklich sorgen ich
denke dass ein großteil der bevölkerung
bereits geimpft ist oder sich angesteckt
hat der staat unternimmt mehr und mehr
schritte um es uns leichter zu machen
man muss auch an die unternehmen denken
man muss öffnen es geht nicht anders
ich denke es gab keine andere wahl als
zu öffnen nach einem jahr mit drei oder
vier hermetischen lockt es im ganzen
land denke ich es ist der richtige
schritt mit corona zu leben und nicht zu
versuchen gegen den wind zu kämpfen
der letzte lockdown ist allerdings schon
eine weile her diese und die letzte
corona welle durch schritt das land im
prinzip ohne auch dass sich geschätzt
zwei bis vier millionen israelis allein
mit omikron infiziert haben änderte
daran nichts denn trotz millionenfachen
impf durchbruchs gab es vergleichsweise
wenig schwere verläufe und eine vierte
impfung schütze viele ältere zusätzlich
von den über 60-jährigen in israel sind
übrigens 92 prozent vollständig geimpft
ein deutlich besserer wert als in
deutschland
doch bei so hohen infektionszahlen
fühlten sich die korona stationen
schnell pflegenotstand denn auch
tausende vom medizinischen personal
vielen infiziert aus sogar nach der
vierten impfung wie die 66 jährige
schwester jaffa
ohne impfung wäre ich viel schwerer
erkrankt wir sehen dass hier auf der
station die ungeimpften leide vielmehr
unter der krankheit als die geimpften
viel mehr
inzwischen ist ein großteil des
pflegepersonals zurück auf den stationen
die zahl der schweren fälle dort stieg
auf ein allzeithoch von 1263 sinkt aber
inzwischen 1100 menschen starben bis
jetzt weniger als bei den letzten wahlen
die meisten ungeimpft oder mit anderen
vorerkrankungen schwester jaffa weg
daher ab ich weiß nicht was ich sagen
soll ich glaube dass die entscheidung zu
öffnen insgesamt richtig ist wir müssen
wieder ins normale leben zurückkehren
wir haben keine andere wahl man muss
wieder die routine haben die menschen
müssen wieder arbeiten können und geld
verdienen inzwischen die app die
comic-con welle langsam ab wir fragen
den gesundheitsminister war der kurs der
regierung trotz der vielen schwerst
kranken und toten verhältnismäßig
ich denke unsere politik ist gut
ausbalanciert und es ist eine gerechte
politik wir haben entschieden der
letzten regierung nicht dabei zu folgen
lockdown zu erklären die clearing
lockdown
corona wird nicht aus unserem leben
verschwinden leider es wird bei uns
bleiben vielleicht für jahre und wir
müssen wege finden um seite an seite mit
corona zu leben
mit dem virus leben auch israels
gesellschaft hat darauf noch nicht die
letzte antwort gefunden
über den israelischen weg hatte ich hier
im heute journal gestern mit
gesundheitsminister lauterbach
gesprochen er warnte dass eine so
radikale öffnung in deutschland aktuell
noch zu hohen todeszahlen führen würde
ein artikel der sich damit noch mal
näher befasst finden sie online auf zdf
heute und jetzt die nachrichten sind
voll die pandemie bedingten sonderregeln
für den bezug von kurzarbeitergeld
sollen weiter verlängert werden um drei
monate bis ende juni das hat das
bundeskabinett auf den weg gebracht wenn
die verlängerung auch den bundestag
passiert können betriebe entsprechend
weiter leichter kurzarbeitergeld
beantragen
und das bundeskabinett hat grünes licht
gegeben für die verlängerung von zwei
bundeswehreinsätzen im ausland die
deutschen beteiligungen am n einsatz
unmis im bürgerkriegsland südsudan sowie
am nato-einsatz sie guardian im
mittelmeer sollen um jeweils ein jahr
fortgesetzt werden sie guardian dient
der überwachung des mittelmeerraums mit
schiffen und flugzeugen unmiss soll den
friedensprozess in süd sudan
unterstützen der bundestag muss darüber
noch abstimmen
für die freien wähler tritt die
kommunalpolitikerin stefanie gebauer zur
bundespräsidentenwahl am kommenden
sonntag an neben amtsinhaber frank
walter steinmeier stehen noch der von
der afg nominierte ökonom max otte und
der von der linken vorgeschlagene arzt
gerhard trabert zur wahl die 41 jährige
promovierte astrophysikerin gebauer ist
vorsitzende der
stadtverordnetenversammlungen kremmen
und wissenschaftliche mitarbeiterin der
brandenburgischen landtags fraktion mit
ihrer bewerbung will die jüngste
kandidatin die jemals für das
bundespräsidentenamt vorgeschlagen wurde
frauen mut machen eine führungsaufgabe
zu übernehmen
mehr als eineinhalb jahre war der
botschafterposten der usa in deutschland
unbesetzt nun soll die politologin und
präsidentin einer universität amy
goodman die vertretung washingtons in
berlin übernehmen der us senat stimmte
für die wunschkandidatin von präsident
biden
nach einem erdrutsch im westen
kolumbiens ist die zahl der opfer auf 15
angestiegen so der nationale
katastrophenschutz und weiterhin werden
einige personen vermisst eine von
heftigen regenfällen ausgelöste
schlammlawine hatte am dienstagmorgen in
einem wohngebiet mehrere häuser zerstört
dutzende menschen mussten sich in
sicherheit bringen und laut behörden
besteht die gefahr weiterer erdrutsche
die ukraine krise hält außenministerin
baerbock in atem da ist gerade nicht
viel raum für spezifisch grüne akzente
die sie aber ja setzen will die deutsche
außenpolitik soll sich stärker um
umweltthemen und klimawandel kümmern
diplomaten auch als klimabotschafter
auftreten dafür holt sich bernburg nun
auch prominenz ins haus jennifer morgen
die chefin von greenpeace international
wechselt ins auswärtige amt in berlin
eine personalie die für braunen sorgt
berichtet heike slansky
eine typische greenpeace-aktion jennifer
morgen in ihrem element die chefin der
klimaaktivisten gegen erdöl bohrungen in
der arktis künftig begibt sich die 55
jährige amerikanerin auf politisches
glatteis als sonderbeauftragte der
bundesregierung im range einer
staatssekretärin das ist für mich eine
traumbesetzung und ein wichtiges signal
für den internationalen klimaschutz ein
herausragender posten angesiedelte im
auswärtigen amt statt im
umweltministerium morgen soll die klima
außenpolitik der bundesregierung steuern
eine aktivistin als staatsdiener in für
die cdu ein problematisches signal
es ist auch eine grenzüberschreitung
wenn man den aktivismus von
nichtregierungsorganisationen
jetzt in eigentlich zielgerichtetes
regierungshandeln in der staatlichen
sphäre übersetzen will das passt nicht
zusammen
das ist nicht in ordnung
morgen ist keine unbekannte auch angela
merkel schätze ihre expertise 2013 wurde
sie in den rat für nachhaltige
entwicklung berufen seit gut fünf jahren
steht sie an der spitze von greenpeace
für lobby control ist der seitenwechsel
unbedenklich
wechsel hinein in die politik aus lobby
organisationen aus unternehmen ist
anders zu bewerten als die wechsel
heraus aus der politik es wichtig dass
auch fach expertise von außen in die
ministerien kommen kann man muss nun
aber trotzdem sagen und genau hinschauen
dass frau morgen hier jetzt nicht
greenpeace interessen in zukunft
vertritt eine gut vernetzte lobbyist den
wechselt in die politik sie verspricht
wenn ich für deutschland spreche dann
natürlich werde ich die positionen der
bundesregierung vertreten nicht von mir
persönlich nicht von irgend eine andere
organisationen ein
umstrittener rollenwechsel ohne
karenzzeit fehlt noch die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft bevor sie als bär box
vertreterin weltweit für den klimaschutz
kämpft
theo koll das ist schon ein
ungewöhnlicher vorgang eine
ungewöhnliche personalie wie wird das in
berlin politisch bewertet also mit lob
mit kritik und mit dem ruf vorsieht
risiko das lob kommt vor allem natürlich
aus den eigenen reihen und der
klimapolitischen zivilgesellschaft
jennifer morgen sei keine herausragenden
kompetente und weltweit vernetzte
kennerin aller klimaverhandlungen und
das ganze eine interessante
internationalisierung die kritik betont
wie eben auch gehört vor allem dass die
grenze zwischen staatsdienst und
aktivismus beziehungsweise lobbyismus
leichtfertig übersprungen werden und es
wird daran erinnert dass die grünen ja
schon während der
koalitionsverhandlungen einen brief an
umweltorganisationen geschrieben und um
unterstützung gebeten hätten und gewarnt
wird vor dem risiko dass sharif am
morgen zwar fachkompetenz er war ja
unvertraut mit dem regierungsapparat und
dass man das beim klima noch
zurückhaltende staaten durch 7 sicher
weise eher verschreckt als gewonnen
würden aber annalena baerbock die
ministerin die erhofft sich davon ja was
ja also sie macht damit zweierlei sehr
deutlich erstens dass außenpolitik
künftig ganz wesentlich auch
klimapolitik ist und das internationale
klimapolitik künftig im auswärtigen amt
nämlich in ihrem ministerium zu hause
ist es stets war auch schon so ähnlich
im koalitionsvertrag
jetzt aber wird es in der person von
jennifer morgen auch mit leben und auch
mit politischer verdrängung gefüllt
morgen werde so sagt annalena baerbock
künftig als steuerfrau die deutsche
klima außenpolitik lenken für robert
habeck
klimaministerium bleibt dann vor allem
viel kärnerarbeit rund um die
energiewende mal ganz zu schweigen vom
deutlich abgewerteten umweltministerium
also die kabinetts kompetenzverteilung
wird durch diese personalie auch
offensichtliche dank seehofer gerne lese
im moment schaut die welt war ja vor
allem auf die klassischen aufgaben der
diplomatie internationales krisen und
konfliktmanagement
kanzler scholz empfängt morgen die
staats- und regierungschefs der drei
baltischen staaten vom konflikt mit
russland sind sie unmittelbar betroffen
und haben erwartungen an deutschland
deutschland führt das nato bataillon im
literarischen ruhm klar und wird jetzt
auch noch mal zusätzliche soldatinnen
und soldaten schicken die towns
geostrategische lage ist besonders
heikel es grenzt an die russische
exklave kaliningrad und an die grenze
zum belarus florian neumann ist für uns
in litauen
der große russische truppenaufmarsch
markt weit weg sein in jona war litauen
das gefühl der bedrohung aber teil jeder
mit dem wir hier sprechen genauso wie
das gefühl der sicherheit das westliche
truppen direkt nebenan vermitteln wir
sehen hier wirklich viel militärisches
gerät wir spüren dass die nato da ist
aber dadurch fühlen wir uns sicherer
unsere hoffnung ist die nato so können
wir ein bisschen besser schlafen
wenn ein krieg passiert dann wir sind
sicher wir sind doch in der nato ja die
nato ist auch in litauen seit genau fünf
jahren unter deutscher führung mit
verstärkter präsenz
aber nein diese gut 1000 könnten das
land im ernstfall er nicht gegen einen
russischen einmarsch verteidigen doch
sie sollen wohl vermitteln dass das
beistands versprechen der nato ernst
gemeint ist
litauen revanchieren sich mit einem
gedenkstein zum fünften jahrestag der
truppenverstärkung und mit dankesworten
sogar auf deutsch
der deutsche kommandeur hagen ruppelt
bekommt noch einen litauischen augen
dann geht es zurück in die heimat
dauerhaft da hier kein soldat der nato
stationiert sein das haben nato und
russland 1997 so vereinbart also tauscht
die nato ihre truppen alle sechs monate
aus und während deutschland in der
aktuellen krise von seinen verbündeten
oft kritisiert wird das land tue zu
wenig gehen sie hier mit gutem gefühl
nach hause
im grunde bin ich sehr froh dass ich als
deutscher offizier wo wir als deutsche
doch jahrelang an der innerdeutschen
grenze von der nato profitiert haben
geschützt wurden das jetzt auch
zurückgeben kann hier an der nato ist
lang ein beitrag zu leisten zu einer
glaubwürdigen abschreckung zu stabilität
und frieden in europa wer aber weiß
der russische präsident putin sich durch
solche übungen der nato kampf gruppe
wirklich abschrecken lässt ob sie ihn
beeindrucken oder ob er sie nicht eher
als provokation des westens auf fast und
wer weiß ob 350 zusätzliche deutsche
soldaten daran etwas ändern der
litauische staatspräsident kann im
zdf-interview gar nicht aufhören die
bundesregierung für diese verstärkung zu
loben nur um dann hinterher zu schieben
es reicht ihm nicht
wir reden nicht mehr über quantität wir
müssen über qualität reden denn bisher
haben wir im baltikum kein system der
flugabwehr
defence in in der wollte griechen
flugabwehrraketen das fordert er nun
auch von deutschland morgen triften aus
jeder dem deutschen bundeskanzler in
berlin
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit dem blick
auf den wirtschaft deutschlands
exporteure haben im vergangenen jahr ein
rekordergebnis verbucht die ausfuhren
legten nach angaben des statistischen
bundesamtes deutlich zu und kamen damit
sogar über das niveau des
vorkrisenjahres
2009 10 bei der halle wie sind die
erwartungen für dieses jahr es könnte
ein ganz gutes jahr werden aber der
aufschwung der steht schon noch auf
wackligen beinen immer noch belasten
lieferengpässe den außenhandel ebenso
wie hohe transportkosten ja und das sind
ja auch probleme die nicht über nacht
einfach so weg gehen also unsicherheiten
ja aber auch viel zuversicht unter
deutschen exporteuren denn den einbruch
in der korona krise haben sie seit 20 21
mehr als wettgemacht 14 prozent plus im
vergleich zum vorjahr
damit liegen deutsche ausfuhren sogar
mehr als dreieinhalb prozent über
vorkrisenniveau
mit abstand wichtigster kunde sind nach
wie vor die usa gefolgt von china und
frankreich
vielversprechend ist dass die industrie
auf prall gefüllten auftragsbüchern
sitzt die chancen für einen längeren
aufschwung stehen also gar nicht so
schlecht entscheidend wird sein wie
lieferketten probleme omikron und der
ukraine russland konflikt sich
weiterentwickeln russland ist zwar kein
top handelspartner deutschlands liefert
aber wichtige rohstoffe wie gas und und
ohne die kann die export maschinerie
nicht reibungslos funktionieren die
starken exportdaten beflügeln auch die
stimmung am aktienmarkt der dax heute
dick im plus mit über eineinhalb prozent
anleger gehen wieder ins risiko die
börsen nehmen fahrt auf unter anderem
weil unternehmen starke bilanzen
vorgelegt haben auch das ein zeichen für
eine robuste konjunkturerholung weil er
half vielen dank
die leipziger buchmesse eigentlich
geplant für mitte märz ist abgesagt
worden zu viele aussteller hätten sich
in der unsicheren pandemie lage gegen
eine teilnahme in leipzig entschieden es
ist die dritte absage der buchmesse seit
beginn der pandemie und
jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am mittwoch
sie lauten wie immer ohne gewähr 16 25
32 33
45 superzahl 3 und weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf de und
auf der zf textseite 557
er ist nach wie vor der wichtigste und
einer der teuersten künstler der
gegenwart
gerhard richter geboren in dresden die
kindheit in nazi terror und krieg die
jugend und der beginn seiner
künstlerkarriere in der ddr die er mit
seiner ersten frau immer 1961 verließ
das junge paar flüchtete über
west-berlin
richter wechselte an die kunsthochschule
in düsseldorf dort wo es damals alle
großen hinzu das war der fluxus das
progressive die zeit des aufbruchs doch
gerhard richter war nie ein künstler der
für eine bestimmte epoche oder eine stil
stand er war sozusagen immer seine
eigene gebrochen seit nunmehr 90 jahren
heute hat er geburtstag viele museen
widmen ihn dazu große ausstellungen und
für uns gratuliert claudia augusta
geburtstags kerze auspusten geht nicht
es ist ja nein kein unscharfes foto
sondern ein gemälde erst am 2 beim
genaueren blick erkennt man die farbe
das ist richter
für zwölf millionen euro über den tisch
gegangen auch das ist richter
und das ist gerhard richter seine wie so
oft kurze antwort auf die frage was hat
sich am meisten verändert in der kunst
der letzten jahrzehnte
so rauschhaft
diese antwort gab er 2008 und er lag
falsch
46 millionen dollar gab es für dieses
abstrakte bild die preise sinken nicht
richter ist die nummer eins in den
hitparaden der gegenwartskunst seit
jahren warum eigentlich
er ist ein stimmungs maler und die
stimmung seiner bilder ist meistens
unaufgeregt ruhig oder sogar beruhigend
auf den ersten blick
das beunruhigende das dunkle ist da aber
es versteckt sich wie schon gesagt für
den zweiten den genaueren blick
gelassen souverän wechselt er die
stilrichtungen und während andere
künstler verzweifelt experimentieren mal
trichter landschaften schlicht und kühl
und einfach schön
einfach schön ist auch seine begründung
warum er so gerne an ausstellungen
mitarbeitet
etwas dazu beitragen
macht ja spaß
[Musik]
die chorfenster in der abteikirche
tholey waren sein letztes großes werk
danach hat er aufgehört zu anstrengend
sagt er
er malt nicht mehr ergibt auch keine
interviews mehr richter alt hat lieber
in würde
heute aber feiert er geburtstag
macht ja spaß
und auf ihr gratulieren das war's im
heute-journal und noch der hinweis aufs
ausland journal mit einem bericht zur
lage der schulkinder in großbritannien
titel das hustende klassenzimmern und um
0.45 gibt es dann unser heute schon ein
update mit nazan guckte mir
damit verabschieden wir uns auf
wiedersehen und hier freuen sich morgen
abend christian sievers ein wunder gause
auf sie
[Musik]
guten abend es war einmal ein orkantief
dieses tief sat 1 wird aber auch uns
beschäftigen und zwar in der nacht auf
freitag morgen haben wir es erstmal mit
dem tief tanja lack zu tun das zieht von
den niederlanden über norddeutschland
weiter richtung baltikum darf hält ein
bisschen regen und zum abend könnte es
dann hier in den mittelgebirgen sogar
mal wieder für etwas schnee reichen
heute nach fällt ein bisschen regen in
norddeutschland im süden es ist dagegen
häufig klar und da bildet sich nebel es
kann glatt werden auf den straßen in
süddeutschland denn dort sinken die
werte auf plus 3 bis minus 5 grad im
norden bleibt es bei 7 bis 4 grad milder
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
meist so bei sieben bis acht grad etwas
milder wird es hier im südlichen
brandenburg in sachsen südlich der donau
und am oberrhein mit 10 bis 14 grad und
so regnet es morgen so ungefähr zwischen
dem niederrhein und der ostseeküste
nachmittag lockern die wolken an der
nordsee schon wieder auf und richtung
süden und südosten ist es deutlich
sonniger und dann kommt dieses ehemalige
kleine orkantief heran bringt uns noch
am freitag kräftige schnee regen und
graupelschauer vielleicht auch mal
gewitter und es wird kälter bei 2 bis 8
grad ähnlich kalt ist es dann auch am
samstag da wird es aber sehr sonnig am
sonntag wird's schon wieder milder und
von nordwesten kommen regen worten haben
und wie sie hier am trend für berlin
sehen können geht es einigermaßen mild
und wechselhaft in den nächsten tagen
weiter guten abend